the UK is my home and a place that I
love that will never change and now
Prince Harry and Megan Merkel are headed
back to England for their first official
joint engagement since their royal exit
a royal source tells ET that the Sussex
is still have some royal duties to
finish up like attending the annual
Commonwealth service at Westminster
Abbey our source confirms that Megan and
Harry will attend the event on March 9th
they'll also make a final round of royal
engagement in the UK before settling in
North America the decision that I have
made for my wife and I to step back is
not one I made likely it was so many
months of talks after so many years of
challenges and I know I haven't always
got it right but as far as this goes
there really was no other option while
Megan and harry's royal life is for the
most part well over our source says the
couple will continue to attend future
family events like trooping the colour
when the Queen extends an invite really
but let's go back to the annual
Commonwealth Service
last year all the talk was about event
very pregnant Megan and her rumored
rocky relationship with sister-in-law
Kate Middleton when they greeted each
other there was a really a really warm
energy between the two of thermus a bit
of a hug a kiss on each cheek you know
that was quite a contrast to the
behavior that we saw last week at the
celebration of Prince Charles's 50th
investor I understand that both of them
have sort of agreed that you know for
the sake of appearances they they really
want it to look as if they get on they
both realize that the idea of a feud you
know a royal cat fight between two
duchesses doesn't help any of them and
let's not forget the Sussex ah's and the
Cambridge's we're all still living at
Kensington Palace they really are just
across a courtyard but so much has
changed since last year first Megan and
Harry split from the royal foundation
and left the royal nest for their new
home at Frogmore cottage
they welcomed their first child son
Archie Harrison in May then last month
they stepped down as senior members of
the royal family and freakin moved to
Canada and I know I haven't always going
to rights but as far as this goes there
really was no other option plus we now
know that the real family feud has been
between Harry and William and it stems
from the early days of Harry's
relationship with Megan William had
voiced concern to Harry about how
quickly the relationship was moving
really questioning whether Harry was
doing the right thing I think that
spawned a resentment in Prince Harry
that has that has festered and that
relationship has has soured and well
considerably so much so that the
brothers really are not on close terms
now last week
et learned that William and Harry are
talking more and they're on better
footing
following Harry and Megan's decision to
step back from the royal family like
we're brothers we'll always be brothers
but it'll be interesting to see the
brotherly dynamic wins the Fab Four
reunite for the Commonwealth Service
next month
[Music]